looking at police reform at this moment
when activists and protesters are
demanding more action and this despite
President Trump signing an executive
order on policing they say it doesn't go
far enough
best-selling author Malcom Gladwell has
written extensively about race and
policing over the years including the
1999 police killing of amadou diallo
right here in New York City Gladwell is
right now launching the fifth season of
his popular podcast revisionist history
it's a podcast that touches on
wide-ranging topics like art museums and
elections and an Air Force general and
the dragon from Hobbit or I should say a
dragon from Hobbit and Malcom Gladwell
joins us now Malcolm good morning and
thank you for being here it's a great
podcast and I think people like it
because they like you they like the way
you think and so while I have you I'm
hoping we can get your thoughts on some
of the news of the moment you're
famously the author of tipping point do
you think when it comes to reforming
police in this country and healing race
relations in this country we have
reached a tipping point well we're
certainly a lot closer to a tipping
point then in my memory you know one of
the reasons in my last book talking to
strangers I wrote about the case of
Sandra bland one of those high-profile
sad tragic encounters between an
african-american police and I said in
the book the reason I wanted to talk
about is that we always have these
incidents and then they go away we you
know we just go on with our lives
and this seems like the first time in a
very long time that we're not content to
go on with our lives and that's
incredibly encouraging that's an
important moment I mean in tipping point
you say you only need 30 percent or
about 30 percent of a population to
start changing the views and the culture
of the entire population and I think the
polls would suggest what we're beyond
that point but let's talk a bit about
how that change happens one of the most
memorable slogans from the
demonstrations is defund the police but
then you've got Republican lawmakers
saying actually we need more money for
police because we've got to retrain them
in these new ways which side of that of
that conversation you come down on where
is the evidence well I'm on either side
at the moment what I want to do is I
want to sit down
let's decide what we want to do how do
we want to reshape law enforcement for
the 21st century to respond to these
very real social realities once we
figure out what we want what how do we
want to retrain people how do you want I
love some of the ideas about changing
the you know removing certain
responsibilities from the police wire
why do armed police do traffic stops why
do they do domestic disturbances why do
they deal with the homeless those are
all things that maybe we should create
another force that deals with those
kinds of social problems and once we've
figured out what we want to do then this
figure out whether it cost more or less
it's crazy to start with the question of
money
but money is gonna be part of it and if
you're talking about changing the job
requirements of police I mean when you
look at it and you look at the evidence
do you think it's gonna mean spending
less on police or putting more money
into it at least in a short term so that
they can retrain and alter their
behavior well I tend to be someone who's
suspicious of the idea that you can fix
something without spending money on it
you know it's a popular lots of you know
conservatives said for years things like
the best way to solve you know the
problem with government was the star of
government I always thought that was a
little crazy and I try to think in my
own life with a number of things that
can be solved by spending less on them
and it's a small list so I'm a little
bit dubious that this is gonna be a cost
saving anyway it's the wrong question
the right question is how do we fix it
and then once we'd answered that [ __ ]
let's just deal with the question of
money well I mean I think it might be
the right question because if you're the
people who are calling for defunding the
police the changes they want you're
suggesting may actually take a little
bit of money up front to see those
implemented but I want to get you on
something that's deeper and more
important at the moment and you know in
the book blink you make a very clear
case for how we fall back on stereotypes
when we're in a tight spot when we have
to think quickly that certainly comes up
in policing so how can you take a
lifetime of experience in an officer's
mind and heart and some
trained that out of them through you
know implicit bias training or some kind
of afternoon workshop you I think
there's a limited amount you could do
with those kinds of that kind of
training and the evidence says that that
training is useful but it's not the
whole answer I think we're gonna have to
end up doing fifty different little
things and hope that they add up to
something major there's no magic bullet
here we're dealing with the cultures of
policing and strategies of policing that
go back many many years that are deeply
ingrained in the law-enforcement
community
this is going to be a long drawn-out
process there's no you know I think
we're not gonna wake up next year and
have how to solve this problem this is
why you know the the important thing
here is for us to all understand this is
a conversation we're gonna have to have
for years and so let's start that
lengthy difficult conversation now and
hope that we wake up ten years from now
and we made significant changes in the
way this this problem unfurls soso so
Malcolm before you go let me ask you
quickly one question about the podcast
and I think I'm reading this correctly
you have an episode in which you make
the case that people should be nihilist
here we are talking about meaningful
change isn't a nihilist if somebody
thinks life itself is meaningless help
me understand
don't know that it's a tongue-in-cheek
episode in which I go back and I talk to
all the people I ever hire and I figure
out am i a good hire or not right do I
do I check all the boxes and build the
right things and turns out I'm a
terrible hire and then I make a kind of
tongue-in-cheek case for hiring people
randomly and it's funny when I conceived
of that it was a sort of a joke but now
in the context of all this discussion
we're having about racial equality I
wonder if it's a serious point well one
of the things that is perpetuated I'm
sorry I'm gonna have to make a blink
like decision here Malcolm we got
fifteen seconds before I'm gonna have a
hard one they're gonna take us off keep
the conversation going
yes I'm glad well thank you very much
for being here the new season of
revisionist history launches tomorrow
and it will be available wherever you
get your podcast